[MUSIC PLAYING]
-Thanks so much, Judy.
Wow.
Somebody really did some
proper sleuthing there.
There were some bits of
bio that I hadn't even
thought about for a long time.
And thank you so much
to you all for coming.
I'm having a really
wonderful year so far,
wandering lonely as a cloud
in my Radcliffe office.
I thought I would try
to do something slightly
different from what I usually do
this afternoon and read poems,
but try to talk a little bit
more around them than normal.
And I guess this is because,
for once, the audience might
actually have more lawyers or
physicists in it than poets.
And I assure you, this
never, ever happens.
So I guess I hoped
that this wouldn't
seem an exercise in saying, oh,
these poems are so difficult.
Look what clever things
I've put into them.
It's more me trying to
show the way that I think
and the sort of
serendipitous connections
and leaps and
suturings of thought
that go into a poem for me.
Given that it's
working, at the end,
towards this current
project of mine,
an erasure poem about and for
Hong Kong called "Two Systems."
There's a sort of
teleological strand
running through this talk.
So the poems I'm
going to read today
might seem a little
bit single-minded,
because they're all,
effectively-- to my mind--
variations on a theme.
So I do have poems about
buses and theoretical physics
and love and walking
home in the rain.
But I'm not going to be
reading any of those today.
And this first
poem, I think, could
act as a sort of prologue.
Because it's the
same but different
to the others, in as much
as all the other poems
I'm going to read
explore the Chinese side
of my heritage via--
more-or-less directly-- my mum.
Whereas, this poem is one
that's firmly placed in England,
my dad's country.
If you drive northeast
from Cambridge, UK--
where I used to live--
for a couple of hours,
you'll eventually
reach a place called
Binham Priory in Norfolk.
And there's a rood
screen there, which
is an object that has
fascinated me for a long time.
I think, partly,
because it feels to me
like history in motion.
It's an emblem of
history in some sense.
So the rood screen,
it's a painting
of saints, which has been
whitewashed and, then,
over-painted in black-letter
script with text
from Cranmer's Bible.
And this was quite common in the
early reformation in England.
And often, the
text painted on top
was of prohibitions
against idolatry.
So this object is
a sort of emblem
of transition from a
medieval culture of image
worship to this sort of
self-proclaimed Protestant
culture of the Word.
But the punctum that made this
into the germ of a poem for me
was the fact that
the fingers that
have rubbed away
at the whitewash
have done it selectively.
So the faces are the
only areas that have
been systematically uncovered.
And as the historian
Eamon Duffy revealed,
people thought of
this of white-washing,
even at the time, as
a reversible process.
That Catholic sympathizers
might whitewash
church art instead of more
permanent sorts of destruction.
So I'm going to read
you this poem called
"Acts and Monuments,"
which has this epigraph,
as obedient children, that you
give not yourselves over unto
your old lusts.
At the priories fall,
its people came too late,
amidst clamour and cries.
The glistering saints, torn
from their Sunday height--
each gilded screen
and tabernacle,
each tilted face quite slubbered
over, washed with white.
As homily blurred into
homily, Binham's flock
continued to gaze.
A whole generation,
disobedient children,
thumbed at the
lime's forgetfulness,
hoping to coax
from stubborn chalk
that serpent's peep-holed
green, a flash of wheatsheaf
hair almost as bright
as it ever was.
What I want to talk about
today goes to the heart,
I think, of what poetry is.
Heather McHugh puts it very
beautifully when she says,
all poetry is fragment.
It's shaped by its
breakages at every turn.
And I suppose, this is the
most recognizable thing
let's you distinguish
verse from prose,
that jagged, broken,
right margin.
Though I am going to actually
read a couple of prose poems
today, which I suppose
trouble that division.
But for me, at least, poetry
is an art, fundamentally shaped
by the white frame
of the page, that's
tuned into the unsung
as much as the singing,
to wordlessness
as much as words.
And so, as that poem "Acts
and Monuments" suggested,
I'm going to be
talking, especially,
to this idea of vacancy
somehow made visible,
how poems might frame an
absence and, in the process,
make it paradoxically
more present.
And this is a painting that does
just this, frame an absence.
It's attributed to a 10th
century Chinese painter Li
Cheng.
But it's actually,
probably, a copy of it
a couple of centuries later.
And my thinking
about this picture
has been really indebted to
the wonderful Chicago-based
art-historian Wu
Hung, who's done
lots of thinking about
ruins and monumentality;
memory, absence, and
presence in Chinese art.
And for him, this picture
is a quintessential example
of something called [CHINESE],
so lamenting the past.
It's sometimes
translated as nostalgia.
But actually, I think
it's not quite nostalgia.
And it's not quite ubi sunt.
It's a bit different to the
idea of confronting ruins
in Western culture.
But it's this moment
when past and present
are standing face-to-face.
But as Wu Hung points out, the
funny thing about this picture
is that this stele--
so stele, of course,
are these monuments which
have names or events
or deeds inscribed on them
that need to be remembered.
It's blank.
So unlike in poems
of the period, which
very commonly depict ruins--
so you have your poet
standing on the
hill looking down
at the ruins of the old
capital and thinking, oh gosh.
Lament, lament past.
What you have here is this
odd displacement, whereby
the stele is intact, right
down to the tortoise base.
In fact, this impression
of wizenedness and ages
is displaced onto these
contorted trees, if anything.
The stele's intact.
But it's blank.
As if the surface, the
inscription, the writing,
has been worn away by time.
And with that in
mind, I want to read
this poem called "Yangtze."
Although I was born and spent
my early childhood in Hong Kong.
I didn't actually ever
visit mainland China
until I was in my early 20s.
And this was back in 2004.
And one of the first things
I did, as good tourists do,
is go on a cruise
down the Yangtze.
But at that time, work for
the Three Gorges Dam project
had already begun.
So the water level had
already risen by 1/3.
So it was up to here in 2004.
Whereas, now, it's
sort of up to here.
So your vista of
valley and gorge
is quite different to how
it was a decade ago now.
But what was most
extraordinary at that time
was traveling down
this landscape,
which felt like it should be in
a classical Chinese painting.
You would periodically encounter
these towns and villages
that had been not just
emptied and evacuated
but positively stripped down
to the bare cause of buildings,
ready to go under the water.
Yangtze.
The moon glimmers in
the brown channel.
Strands of mist wrap
the mountainsides,
crowded with firs.
Declining cliffs sink beneath
fast water, by remote paths,
twisting pines.
Far downstream, two sides of a
half-built bridge fail to meet.
Our crude boat, chugging,
points to Chongqing.
As someone I now forget once
said, journeying is hard.
My face greets the
evening breeze.
I listen, the dream of a place.
A cormorant dives
by trembling light.
From the white eyelet of a
star, the sound of ripples.
A fishermen skirting shore
in his high-prowed skiff,
crossing bamboo oars, comes up
with a jolt. Nets catch, not
fish, but the wizened finger
of a submerged branch.
For below, a sunken
valley persists.
Slick, bare trunks,
furred in wafting fronds,
have water for
sky, ghost forest.
Roots rot deep in the hill
where buried rock is still dry.
Windows film, doors drift open
in the empty concrete shells
of houses.
Towns that once held hundreds of
thousands slowly filling with--
What?
What is it they fill with?
Someone I now forget once
said, journeying is hard.
The moon glimmers in
the brown channel.
Wu Hung says one more
interesting thing
about this picture,
which is that it
has a relationship with the
convention for representing
Chinese ancestral tablets
in art of this period,
that they too are
depicted as blank tablets.
And the idea was that
you should project,
into that space, the image
of your own ancestors.
This is something
that is especially
interesting and tinged
with sadness for me.
Because my mum was an orphan.
So I have never known any
Chinese family except for her.
So when I look into the blank
of my mental ancestral tablet,
it is literally blank.
And this is something that feeds
into the title poem of my book,
"Loop of Jade."
You're not meant to be able
to read this, by the way.
This is just to show you what
it looks like on the page.
The poem takes its title
from the jade bracelet--
this one-- that my
grandmother gave me as a baby.
And the poem is a way to think
about lines of inheritance,
search for roots, but also
things that one might not
want to pass on.
But the most important things
in the poem are left unsaid.
So for example, my grandmother
wasn't my grandmother by blood.
And indeed, I never knew her.
But she was, rather, the
women who, after my mom
was born and
abandoned, slightly,
tenuously took her
in, adopted her.
This was in Guangdong
Province in 1948, '49.
So the Communists
came to power just
as my mom was a few months old.
And then, this woman took
her just across the water
to the safe haven
of Hong Kong Island.
So this is to illustrate
that the poem takes place
in this counterpoint
of two shapes.
And I've only actually
performed this poem once before.
And I think that experience
showed me that I'm not really
quite up to it.
Because it demands two voices,
which I can't quite do.
So the prose sections
are putatively me.
And then, the little
sections tell the story
of the butterfly
lovers, which is
a folktale that all Chinese
children would know.
Which goes something
like, girl disguises
herself so she can go to school.
Falls in love with fellow pupil.
But when she's married off to an
older man, he dies from grief.
And then, she hauls
herself into his grave.
Everything's awful.
But then, God takes pity.
And they're turned
into the butterflies.
And they're reunited.
And it's only towards
the end of the poem
that you discover that these
fragments of this story
are being told in
my mother's voice.
So I thought I would just read
a couple of the prose sections.
And by the way, I should say
that this alternation of prose
and verse is something
that was inspired
for me by a Japanese form
called haibun, which is actually
how many of the original
haikus were presented.
You would have these
journalistic prose, every day
sections and, then,
this heightening
into little haiku sections.
So I thought I'd read a
couple of the prose sections.
And then, there's a change
of key on the last two pages
of the poem.
So the penultimate
section, this one--
which is about trying
to score visually,
hesitation, difficulty.
Not so much a
physical stuttering
as a sort of
psychological hesitation.
This is in my mum's voice.
And then, this last section
is back to me again.
And you can follow along in
the handout, if you want to.
But actually, I
wouldn't recommend it.
When the television has stayed
on too long, the channels ended
and all the downstairs
lights switched off
but one, sometimes,
rarely, my mother
will begin to talk
without prelude or warning
about her growing up.
Then, her words feel pulled from
a dark and unreflective well,
willed, and not willed.
It isn't that this
tacit contract is not
tinged by our same
daily fumblings,
but when the men
are asleep, I think
she believes it's someone
else's turn to listen.
Once she spoke of her
horror as a very small child
at the communal kitchen in
their low-rise tenement.
Half-outdoors in
that muggy climate,
it ran across the whole
row, a corridor or terrace.
This space-- aside from
housing a blackened, static wok
the size of a Western baby's
bath-- was also a latrine.
Of squatting barefoot over
the cracked tile trench
and trying not to breathe.
How, despite
themselves, her eyes
would follow to the nearby
drain, as it sprouted-- here,
she giggles, shivers--
the glistening bodies
of cockroaches, like
obscene sucked sweets.
I see them, the color
of rust or shit,
hitching up from the
crusted grill on agile legs.
Things scuttling from some
dank, subterranean chamber
of the head.
Her longest and most
empty pause, I've learned,
comes before the word
"mother," as in, my-- mother,
she could speak Shanghainese.
This, one of her trademark
non-sequiters-- at the table,
the family would laugh-- arrived
while scraping off dinner
plates several months after
a trip of mine to Shanghai.
It's as though she's
been conducting
the conversation in
her head for some time
and decides, disconcertingly,
to include you.
Or one Christmas, tucking
the cooled mince pies
into kitchen paper-- I sometimes
think she wasn't very reliable,
my mother.
What she told me, I don't
know how much I can believe.
In her mouth, that
noun worried at me.
For I would never
naturally use it
myself-- mother-- except
at an immigration office,
perhaps, to total strangers
or inside the boundaries
of a poem.
She places it in the
room's still air,
with a kind of resolve
and, yet, a sense
it's not quite right,
and mis-translation.
Like watching her wade
one dredged step at a time
out into a wide gray
straight, myself a
waving spot, unseen,
on the furthest shore.
There was a man in
a nearby district.
When I was young and my
mother short of money,
there was a while--
a lot of times
actually-- when I was sent
to live with other people.
That man was one
of those people.
Looking back, it was better
than the school on Macau.
I learned more at his house.
There were other children
, other girls there too.
At night, he would teach
us the old stories,
all singing together.
People, they used
to talk about him.
These weren't just nursery
rhymes, though I had never
heard those before either.
I mean, the classical
legends and tales.
He had a bad reputation.
The legends, like
Shakespeare, had
a lot of girls who
dress up as boys,
so they will be allowed
to go to school or to war.
My mother heard about it,
had me sent back to her.
When I was old enough, I had
to go to the school instead.
There was one-- "The
Butterfly Lovers"--
it was a poem and also a song.
I used to be able
to sing it all.
He was kind to me.
I didn't think I ever
taught you that one.
It thuds into my chest, this
pendant ring of milky jade.
I wear it strung on an
old watch chain, meant
for a baby's bracelet.
Into it's smooth
circlet, I can just
fit a quincunx of
five fingertips.
Cool on my palm, it
rests, the sinople eye
on a butterfly's wing.
When I was born, she took
it across to Wong Tai Sin--
my mother's mother--
to have it blessed.
I saw that place-- it's
joss-stick incensed mist,
the fortune-casting herd, their
fluttering, tree-tied pleas--
only later, as a tourist.
As for the jade, I never
wore or even saw it then.
The logic runs
like this-- if baby
falls, the loop of
stone-- a sacrifice-- will
shatter in her place.
Painfully knelt
on the altar step,
did the old woman shake out
a sheath of red-tipped sticks
and pick one to entreat my fate?
And if I break it
now, will I be saved?
At exactly the same time as I
was working on that poem, "Loop
of Jade," I also started
work on a sequence
of poems-- very
different poems, not
really autobiographical
in impetus,
though I guess they do touch
on my life in certain oblique
ways-- based on Borges'
famous Chinese encyclopedia.
I'm sure many of you know this,
possibly, encountered it--
as I did-- in the preface to
Foucault's Order of Things,
where Foucault talks about this
laughter that shattered all
the landmarks of our thought.
I'll just read it.
"These ambiguities,
redundancies, and deficiencies
recall those attributed
by Dr. Franz Kuhn
to a certain
Chinese encyclopedia
entitled, The Celestial Emporium
of Benevolent Knowledge.
On those remote
pages, it is written
that animals are divided into,
A, belonging to the emperor;
B, embalmed; C, tame;
D, sucking pigs;
E, sirens; F, fabulous;
G, stray dogs;
H, included in the
present classification;
I, frenzied; J,
innumerable; K, drawn
with a very fine camelhair
brush; L, others; M,
having just broken
the water pitcher;
N, that from a long way
off look like flies."
[LAUGHTER]
So this Chinese encyclopedia
is cited-- which is to say,
invented-- by Borges
in one of his essays.
And I guess I always thought,
being half Chinese, half
English, that this
piece of writing
was somehow describing me.
And I think Foucault is
right when he recognizes
that this is not so much
about the "exotic" charm
of another system of thought.
It's about the
limitations of our own.
So what I did was
I wrote 14 poems,
one for each of the 14 animals.
Like this one,
"d, sucking pigs."
So these poems use
Borges' animals
as a way of thinking about
cultural and racial hybridity,
I suppose-- my own.
Also, some of the
later poems get
into my own "mixed" marriage.
When my husband--
who's Jewish-- and I
were planning our
wedding, we thought
it would be nice to somehow
convey aspects of our heritage.
So we splashed a
glass-- mazel tov!
But then, I was
trying to read around
to find out what Chinese aspects
we could put into our ceremony.
And I came across
this custom whereby
the groom's family, upon
being reassured, shall we say,
of the bride's chastity,
are supposed to give
her family a roast piglet.
[LAUGHTER]
In England, I sometimes
have to gloss shikse.
And I know that they
should strictly be blonde.
But here we are in the land
the Seinfeld and Philip Roy.
And this poem is actually
a Shakespearean sonnets,
albeit with fuzzy rhymes.
That is a technical term.
But in the couplet at the end,
the second line is a footnote.
Right.
Sucking pigs.
Between choosing
canapes and favors,
I read how the groom's
family, by Chinese tradition,
should gift to her kinsmen
a piglet, milk-fed, just
a moon at the teat,
crisped to perfection.
When quite satisfied,
the bride's still intact.
I imagine your mother
cranking the spit.
Crackling's coy,
brittle russet, then,
succulent fat-- that atavistic
aroma makes me salivate-- you,
physically sick.
So as pet-names go,
Shikse's not a bad fit.
I did play your
Circean temptress.
Wikipedia says it comes
down from Leviticus,
how your God labeled
creatures unclean to ingest
but, then, disgust seems
to blur into reverence.
Cf.
Xu Bing, "A Case Study
of Transference."
[LAUGHTER]
So I guess I liked the
idea that-- in these sort
of cod, scholarly,
hyper-referential, encyclopedia
poems-- you might think that
a case study of transference
is some reference to a piece
of psychoanalytic literature.
But I also liked
the idea that people
who know the work of the
Chongqing born Chinese artist
Xu Bing might connect it
to this piece of 1994.
Those are, actually,
two live pigs
in a pen in an
art gallery space,
which are doing their thing.
And the male-- as you
can possibly make out--
is inscribed with Latin
text, whilst the female
is inscribed with Chinese text.
But what you probably can't
see from the zoomed out view
is that it's actually nonsense
written on both of them.
So you can see that this is
no language, this Latin script
at the top.
And the Chinese characters
are these nons made-up ones
that Xu Bing had
actually come up
with for a project of a
couple of years earlier called
[CHINESE], which translates
as "A Book from the Sky,"
which is a Chinese idiom
meaning nonsensical or illegible
language from codes or down to
a doctor's illegible scrawl.
So nonsense is
actually something
that I like to think about and
play with a lot in my work.
Though that's not going
to come up so much today,
right until the very
end of my reading.
And I sometimes wonder
if this has anything
to do with growing up hearing
my mum-- and everyone in Hong
Kong-- speaking Cantonese, a
language I couldn't understand.
And I wonder if that
experience somehow made
me a poet, or at least more
susceptible to language
as sound and cadence
separated from sense.
Now, I'd like to read three more
poems from the Borges sequence,
a little trio or
subgroup, all of which
relate to censorship
in one way or another.
So I didn't speak Cantonese
when I was growing up.
I only learned
Mandarin as an adult.
And as I went through this
process of painstakingly--
and with great difficult--
learning this tremendously hard
language, one of the things that
struck me most was all the ways
that Chinese can pun
that English just can't.
So the characters,
the written system,
allow for this in one way.
When a character
differs from another
by just one dot or stroke,
they'll look similar
but have entirely
different meanings.
And this is a sort of
punning that became
very important to the
protesters in the visual culture
of the recent Umbrella Movement
in Hong Kong, for example.
But even more common
is puns based on sound,
because Chinese is so
full of homophones.
So things will sound almost
exactly the same, or exactly
the same, bar the
differences in tone.
And I thought it was fascinating
that this is something that
has become a way for
Chinese dissidents
to either get round
or protest censorship,
the so-called "Great
Firewall" of China.
And so I think Borges would
have approved of the fact
that the now rather notorious
grass-mud horse of the top
left-- for some reason
they look like alpacas--
first arose early
in 2009, as part
of a hoax on the online
interactive encyclopedia
of Baidu-- the sort
of Chinese equivalent
of Wikipedia-- where
people entered these 10
mythical creatures into the
encyclopedia, all of which
had these names that
sound like obscenities
of one sort or another.
So the grass-mud horse became
a widespread, hugely popular,
internet meme in
China in 2009 and on,
and gave rise to
this whole menagerie
of subversive animals,
including its mortal enemy,
the river-crab, whose
name sounds almost exactly
like "harmony," which, you
know, harmonious society.
It's become a euphemism
in contemporary Chinese
whereby, when you say
you harmonize something,
you mean you censor it.
So two other memes turn
up in this next poem--
the Elephant of Truth,
which apparently
has been on the endangered
species list since 1949;
and also the sensitive
fragile-porcelain meme.
I didn't I need to
say anything else,
except maybe that
Cangjie, the court
historian of the Yellow
Emperor, makes a cameo here,
as the legendary inventor
of Chinese characters.
Having just broken
the water pitcher.
This poem has an epigraph from
a collection of koans called,
"The Gateless Gate,"
which goes, Baizhang
picked up a water
picture, set it on a rock,
and posed this question.
If you cannot call it a water
pitcher, what do you call it?
This fact I can't
forget, my 30th year
had hastened by before I learned
to see how plum blossom lies
one side-long stroke
of gum-suspended soot
away from regret.
It's said, the man who
invented writing-- charged
with this burden
by the emperor--
sought inspiration in the
surface moods of water.
That he was by the
river when he spied,
in the finely cracking
mud, a footprint-- its brim
still is a bronzed
mirror, stamped there
by some invisible creature--
and understood his task.
The moment he sketched
the first character,
the sky rained millet.
And the ghosts wailed all
night, for they could not
change their shapes.
5,000 years later, in some
remote coal-mining district,
sits an anonymous blogger,
his face lit by more than just
the ancient monitor.
He ponders how strange
it is, how useful
that "I beg you for the
truth" is pronounced the same
as "I beg you,
Elephant of Truth."
Or that sensitive words-- as
in "filters," "crackdowns"--
sounds exactly like
"breakable porcelain."
Done typing, he clicks Submit.
Recall the old monk's
koan, the correct reply
to Master Baizhang's
question-- his pupil
kicked over the
pitcher and left.
This next poem
revisits a figure who's
been really important
to me in my own work.
He's quite a troublesome
figure in lots
of ways, Ezra Pound, one of
the founders of modernism
in English.
I think Eliot was
right when he said
that Pound was the inventor of
Chinese poetry for our time.
And that's still true now.
Eliot based that
judgment on "Cathay."
Maybe some of you will
know it, published
in 1915, Pound's
free translations
from the classical
Chinese poet Li Bai,
which-- whenever you read
Chinese or Chinese-sounding
poetry these days-- is still
drawing on "Cathay," basically.
But this page here
is actually from
his epic, unfinished, huge,
sprawling work of synthesizing
historical and poetic
imagination-- deeply flawed,
but also, I think,
rather brilliant--
called the cantos,
which he worked on
for much of his adult life.
And as you can see, one of
the most immediately striking
things about the cantos is
that they have these Chinese
characters in the margins, in
Pounds rather dodgy Chinese
script. ; Which, of course, is
something I recall deliberately
in my own work and book.
The reason Pound is such
a troubling character--
there are many.
But one of them is his
pro-fascist and violently
anti-Semitic wartime speeches
for Radio Rome, which
were what landed him--
after his arrest in 1945--
in a death-cell at the US Army
Disciplinary Training Center
just outside of Pisa.
And the mental
instability fostered
by these hellish conditions
he met in the cage
were actually what
eventually saved Pound
from the scaffold
for treason, in favor
of a American mental hospital,
St. Elizabeth's, where he spent
most of the rest of his life.
The last cantos
that he wrote often
are called the "Pisan Cantos."
And it's not straightforward,
ethically, to be moved by them.
But I find myself moved
by them, especially
passages like this
famous on in Canto 74,
when an African-American
soldier, Mr. Edwards,
brings Pound a packing
crate to his medical tent
to use as a writing table.
The "Pisan Cantos,"
elsewhere, are
horribly racist about
Pound's African-American gods
and fellow soldiers.
But this moment does have
it's tug on the heart strings.
So where the last
poem and the next one
are to do with circumventing
censorship, this one,
I sort of conceived as
being about where we might
draw the lines of free speech.
Oh, by the way, Kung
Fu-tzu or Kongzi
is the Chinese
name of Confucius.
Stray dogs.
Thou art a beaten
dog beneath the hail.
To think again of Pound,
bared to the sky at Pisa.
The traitor's cage they built
for him specially, 6 by 6 feet
of air-strip mesh and dust.
Wire diamonds shadowed
starkly under foot.
Day 25, DTC doctors transfer
him to a medical tent--
a swollen magpie
in the fitful sun--
fearing the first
signs of a breakdown.
Three weeks in
this here sun going
to change a man,
thinks Mr. Edwards, he
with the face of
the Baluba mask,
as he flips over
a packing crate--
hang regulations-- to fashion
the traitor a writing table.
Squat at his
crate-cum-desk, Pound
spreads flat the worn-out covers
of his dog-eared Confucius.
He'd slipped it in his
slacks' side-pocket that day
at the house, a rifle
butt pounding the door.
As he flicks through
the "Analects,"
his hand starts to tremble.
He pushes it hard into
his temple, takes up
the donated pencil stub.
Pull down thy vanity,
near illegible.
Scrawling on squares of
shiny latrine roll, now
lodged in a library's vaults.
Later, he gets hold of a
GI pad, ruled lines turned
90 degrees, like bars.
No longer blithely
ranting on Rothschilds
as in his radio days--
whether they are
born Jews or taken to Jewry.
Circe's sty, glorious cant.
Our captive flutters again
to the much-thumbed page
where, having lost his disciples
at the city's east gate,
Kung takes with equanimity
the stranger's slur.
Look at this man here.
He has a face like a lost dog.
Yes, smiles Kung Fu-tzu, yes.
That's quite correct.
That poem is, of course, just a
sequence of terrible dog puns,
including that Ezra
got sent to the pound.
[LAUGHTER]
The third in the trio-- by
way of indirect preamble.
This is a photograph I took
in a public park in Chengdu
a couple of years ago.
And those of you who
have been to China
have maybe seen this phenomenon
of writing calligraphy--
in this case, a poem
by Li Bai-- in water,
using a giant brush on the
paving stones in parks.
So I spoke just now about
Xu Bing's [CHINESE], Books
from the Sky.
This is [CHINESE],
so ground-calligraphy
or books from the ground.
I sort of like that connection.
It's a practice
that-- from what I
can tell-- seemed to arise
in public parks in Beijing
in the 1990s, but then
spread around the country.
And this is the
old man in question
with his admiring
audience of-- I
think they were
physio-therapy students.
But anyway, this practice
of ground-calligraphy,
I think it chimes with a
certain strand of evanescence
or disappearance in Chinese
art of recent decades.
So Song Dong, a
Beijing-born artist,
who began at an early age as a
painter but-- after the events
in Tienanmen of 1989-- was
traumatized and stopped work
for years, before returning
as a conceptual artist.
In 1995, maybe having seen these
old man in the Beijing parks,
Song began to keep a daily
journal, which he wrote out
in water on a large flat stone,
so that his record of his days
vanished faster than
the days themselves.
The following year, in '96, on
a freezing New Year's Night,
Song performed a piece
called "Breathing."
He lay down in Tienanmen
Square, his face
to the ground, his lips
almost touching the pavement.
And for the next 40
minutes, his clouded breath
played over the concrete
flags, the vapor freezing
into a thin sheet of ice,
which lasted for a few hours
and, then, was gone by morning.
So this photograph
and a couple of others
are the only record
of this performance.
I'm working my way
round to Hong Kong.
This, by the way, isn't how
this poem appears in my book.
I just got excited by
the gradient-fill button
on PowerPoint.
[LAUGHTER]
In Chinese, the Tienanmen
incident of '89 isn't known
by its place name, but by
the date, June 4, [CHINESE]--
references to which are
censored on the mainland.
For a time, the
invented date, May 35,
allowed Chinese web users
to circumvent the ban.
Hong Kong is the
only place in China
where the anniversary can
be publicly commemorated.
And mass candlelit vigils
take place every year.
And actually, they grow in
force and numbers every year.
I won't say too much, because
it's all in the poem really.
But this is my recollection
of a solidarity protest,
a sort of fundraising
event that took place
in Hong Kong in support of
the students in Tienanmen
at the end of May 1989.
Even I think I
remember that this
was a euphoric moment
in Hong Kong, when
hundreds of thousands of
people flooded into the streets
in support of the Chinese
democracy movement
and thought that China would
be reborn in Hong Kong's image.
We still don't know how many
people died in the square.
Innumerable.
Poem on the eve of May 35.
In the early summer of
1989, when I was five,
my parents took me
on an unusual outing.
It wasn't that the Jockey
Club's Happy Valley track--
at that time, still epitheted
"Royal"-- was unfamiliar to me.
Every week, I went there for
an hour's swimming lesson
in the too-hot pool.
My reward, an orange ice-lolly
from the freezer cabinet
behind the clubhouse bar.
But I knew things were
different that morning.
For one, I had never trod
on the actual grass before.
On race days, that
was the preserve
of the slow-processing row
of black-trousered laborers,
their cone hats and
canes, who would follow on
after the rumbling
of the horses.
Their job-- with the
practiced touches
of the blind-- to feel out
the slightest hoof-flung sod
and tamp it back into
the reperfected turf.
I spent the day hoisted
on my father's shoulders,
staring out across the
jellied mass of human heads.
On the big screen,
the dots of light
weren't tickering the customary
shifting dance of odds,
but the exact words
that would rise
from the rippling mouth
in the stands' atoll,
as the crest of
skyscrapers stood watch.
On the news that
evening, I tried
to pick out my waving
self among the banners'
swell, the toy-box people
chanting and abuzz.
A few days later, there were
different pictures on the news.
A man, with two
white shopping bags,
edging crabwise on a faceless
boulevard in another city
where, 23 years later, I would
struggle for over half an hour
to hail a cab.
On rainy race days,
the turf workers--
still bamboo-brimmed--
would wear transparent macs,
dotted with drizzle, and the
determination of a search
party.
Where they press the clumps
back down, you would never know.
And now, finally,
onto my new project,
"Two Systems," which I'm
working on here in Radcliffe.
Though, I actually
began work on this poem
even before the Umbrella
Movement gained momentum.
I started writing it in the
summer of 2014, last year.
It's an erasure poem that
takes as its source text
the basic rule of
Hong Kong, which
is often called the former
colony's mini-Constitution.
And it's a document
that was negotiated
by Beijing and London through
my childhood in '80s Hong Kong.
So I sort of grew
up in the shadow
of the countdown towards
handover, which was
agreed in '84, when I was one.
The title itself is an erasure.
It refers to one country,
two systems-- of course,
the principle that
Hong Kong's way of life
should stay unchanged
for 50 years
after the handover date
on 1st of July, 1997.
One country, two
systems supposedly
guarantees a high-degree
of autonomy from China.
But what this
means is constantly
being negotiated and
feared over right now.
So I guess, the idea that Hong
Kong should remain a civil law
jurisdiction within a civil
law state, a capitalist pocket
in a socialist
framework, and so on.
But what intrigued me
about the basic law
is that it's a
self-deconstructing-- you might
even say,
self-destructing-- text,
which enshrines within itself
the date of it's undoing, 2047.
On the basis that I think
that you are all probably
more familiar with the Umbrella
Movement in Hong Kong than
you are with the history
of the erasure poem.
I could be wrong.
I thought I'd give
you a posit history
to show that this is far from
something that I've invented.
So I guess it was popular with
Western avant garde writers
since the '60s.
And so, this is a famous example
called Ronald Johnson's RADI
OS of 1977, which erased most
of Milton's Paradise Lost,
to give rise to these new,
surprisingly affecting work.
It's often praised for being
Pound-like in its imagism,
out of the earlier
poem's rubble.
Johnson described his process
as being like etching,
cutting away at each page.
And indeed, erasure poetry
does have visual qualities
that I think place it somewhere
between art and literature.
And it's rise
probably has something
to do with contemporary
developments
in the visual arts.
So like Rauschenberg's Erased
de Kooning Drawing, which
does what it says on the tin.
So I've been trying to think
about this visual dimension
since I've been at Radcliffe,
the texture, the materiality,
or otherwise of erasure.
And I think Travis McDonald's
"The Omission Repo,"
is particularly interesting
in this respect.
McDonald's source text is
the 9/11 Commission Report,
which gives his work an
obvious political valence.
But he also has these three
different strategies for part
effacing the background text.
So by the way, I
think this is the best
page in the whole poem.
We have tried to remember
that sight can sometimes
see what happened in shadow.
It's good, isn't it?
So like here, a sort
of fade or a blur
or a strike-through-- which
reminds me of the fact
that George W. Bush's
favorite writing instrument
was reportedly a Sharpie marker.
Oh, and this is Tom Phillips'
"A Humament," and which
is based on W.H. Mallock's
late Victorian novel, A Human
Document.
Which sort of takes the visual
dimension to another level
that I'm not sure I can
personally arise to.
I'm just going to read
you this first page
of "Two Systems," though I've
given you three in the handout.
And so, as I said,
I started working
on this piece in the
early summer of 2014,
when Beijing released
a white-paper that
caused widespread
consternation in Hong Kong
and was one of the spurs towards
the Occupy Central Umbrella
Movement.
One of the things they were
particularly afraid about
was the idea that
Hong Kong judges might
have to show fealty to Beijing.
So I found it satisfying,
in a childlike way,
to set about these pages from
the basic law with Photoshop's
eraser tool, so releasing
their anarchic, subversive,
gloriously vulgar undersongs.
But you find in amongst
the nonsense touches
of sense starting to
emerge, including illusions
to the current unrest
about Hong Kong's path
to universal suffrage.
So I'll read it from
this first page.
The court of Kong is rat
hall, diction over acts
such fence and reign affairs.
Our region shall obtain
a cat on quest, the cat
of Cat Hall, before all.
EG joy, power to
the people, he-he.
[LAUGHTER]
I've never read that before.
Zen shall entitle the
age to dance, number
the citizens among the elect,
work the high organ of men
over and over.
Mini rat, mini dance.
There is a need for art.
[LAUGHTER]
I won't read the second page,
though it's in the handout.
But what I found
was interesting,
these characters
start to emerge,
as I do more and more
of this, I guess in line
with the repetitions
in the legal text.
So there's this sort of
hapless character called
Reg on this page-- Reg must
obtain the approval of people--
who, in my mind, was a sort of
allusion to the colonial past.
Reg, for me, is like
an irreverent nod
to the Regina versus X
formula of English law.
So he's this cut-down
version of Regina.
And then, by this
final page-- which
is the one seeking to define
a Hong Kong resident-- hardly
anything is left, except
that haunting date of 2047.
So I'm sure we can
talk more about this.
But I think it's probably
time to open up for questions.
[APPLAUSE AND MUSIC]